happy International Women's Day today's
video is about an awesome project that I
did with an organization called built by
girls both my girls repairs the next
generation of female leaders creators
and builders to boldly step into their
careers powered by technology and for
International Women's Day they are
launching a campaign called this is a
world built by girls and I was lucky
enough to be a part of this campaign
where they flew me out to New York City
to be on set to capture some extra
content the campaign features amazing
honest conversations between tech
leaders and experts and professionals
advisors talking to advisees who are
mostly students who have also made a
name for themselves where they have a
really honest discussion about being a
woman in the workplace and the tech
industry I loved being a part of this
campaign because being there in New York
City with everybody and listening to the
conversations happen live where then it
was just incredible I got so much energy
from them and they are the most
motivational and inspiring talks that
I've heard a long time and I was there
to capture some extra content and so in
this video I wanted to highlight the
amazing advisors who were part of this
campaign so we played a little fun game
together
Allu game that I like to call yes or
pass basically I gave these advisors
various topics about career development
and the tech industry and I asked them
to yes or pass something and explain why
I thought it would be a quick and fun
way to get some honest opinions about
being in and around the tech industry
don't forget to watch to the end for a
preview of the amazing interviews that
all these women have done and without
further ado I will begin by introducing
these incredible advisors let's get
started
do you want me to do you want you want
me do
okay you got it girl okay okay I'm Maura
I'm the co-founder of shine and shine is
a daily pep talk in your pocket we will
help you wake up every morning feeling
like I got this I do what she does Naomi
I'm Angelica Ross aka candy or impose on
FX and I'm also the founder of Transtech
social enterprises hi I'm Claire
Wasserman and I'm the founder of ladies
get paid we're a career development
organization that helps women negotiate
for pay and for power at work I'm Lauren
Casson co-founder and CEO of the wing
which is a network of women's focus work
and community spaces around the country
I really don't see where the suit and
tie or business formal attire really fit
into the tech world I do say that when
you're interviewing for a tech job you
do want to put your best foot forward
but that's sometimes just looking
polished that's just looking like you
fit into the environment so before you
go in that interview maybe do a little
research about the company and not just
about who they are but who are the
people that show up to work and how do
they show up to work so that you show up
in an environment that matches I would
say yes in that it's important to fail
if you're learning I think there needs
to be a tagline under that that's also
like fill thoughtfully because if you're
not learning and you're not actually
reflecting on those failures you feel in
the big way path I think I know it's a
popular one in the tech industry but I
think it leads to more bad
good at times and so I also think it's
an outdated phrase
so the expression fake it till you make
it
I love the sentiment of it right it
basically means you know ask like the
person that you want to become right
before you're actually there that's
great I think the word fake is
problematic right because we want you to
be as authentic and present as possible
so maybe just imagine yourself but older
right
what would this older successful version
of you do in this situation so it's not
really fake it's just you sort of
projecting ahead pass I hate the
statement fake it till you make it I
used to love it but in this day and age
there are too many people faking it and
it's hard to find the real ones it's
hard to find sometimes well it's not
hard if you're really looking because I
believe that when you are dedicated to
your craft it shows a difference and so
instead of faking it to you make it what
I would say for folks is if you're not
quite where you want to be if you
haven't made it yet be willing to do the
work that others have done to get there
so whatever education you need whatever
experience you may need don't fake it
just go get it I think there's there's
definitely a uniform to a certain type
of persona and I don't think you should
have to fit any type of persona to be in
this industry
however being comfortable is really
important you know be mindful the
situation that you're in and in what
feels like the best kind of foot forward
in that situation if you want to wear a
hoodie and like really jump on in I love
a hoodie my mom actually criticizes the
amount of hoodies I still have from high
school so this is very personal for me
um and yeah play I went to comfort but I
think the I think the idea that you like
need to have a certain tacky uniform
yeah um is what it's just not it's not
working yeah I'm dating right and I
think that that these seemingly silly
things are at like what do you wear can
actually perpetuate unconscious bias or
just being very mindful
mindful of that past I I think there's
other ways to bond with people and I
think happy hours are a little outdated
and don't actually lead to genuine
connections in conversation so I passed
I personally like happy hours at work
but I don't think you have to look at
that as your only opportunity to get to
know your colleagues I'm really a big
fan of coffee dates especially
one-on-one so you can really get to know
the people that you work with you know
I'll be always within reason
but I personally enjoy a happy hour yes
it's addictive and I have many a day so
I love Lacroix and that makes me basic
so be it
it's delicious my god I'm not gonna sit
here and defend it it is delicious yeah
we don't have a big fridge in our office
but what is taking up the most amount of
space is Lacroix ah the peach like the
peach one peach one Pamplemousse again
very basic way listen it's grapefruit
and French like that's sort of you know
very glamorous great fruit flavor mmm
but the mousse but we love Lacroix so
much it's someone on our team dressed up
as a quarry for Halloween so I believe
in unlimited vacation policies I really
do because in an environment where
everyone's hungry and excited about
bringing themselves to work we need
those moments where people can take a
break and sometimes as many breaks as
they need in order to come back fully
ready to do that work and we as
companies need to be able to have our
environments ready for people to leave
and have other people come in to pick up
the slack or what have you
that's one thing that I really like
about working with freelancers
especially with Transtech my company
because people go through different life
challenges one day is harder than the
next they may need some off time or what
have you and I don't want that to seem
like a debt
I want people to take the time they need
to heal to regroup to come back and be
100 but in the meantime them knowing
that okay while you're doing that no
problem
I still need someone to work on this
project take your time I'll have them
working on this your job will be back
when you get back yeah yes so we have an
unlimited vacation policy and I know
it's controversial because there
certainly can be a chilling effect and
that some people feel that they're not
able to take their vacation
whenever values is actually go big and
go home and I think that that really
helps that we live and breathe that and
it's really just about like being a
whole human like the work getting done
and then enjoying yourself outside of
work yeah it's a yes cuz like Marr was
saying it's about output it's not about
effort like if the effort doesn't get to
what we need to get done it doesn't
matter how much our little we're working
it matters about like you know making
progress on the most important things
that matter for our members we trust
that people are able to manage their own
time and manage their output and so as a
result that's that's the mindset behind
you know unlimited vacation because
we're all we're all adults we trust our
team
[Music]
hey hey what my girls
I thought my girl and a newcomer to the
tech world what a nice you have to eat
so I can show that it just escaped me
achieve these I said mimics tech it's
such an animated industry that I think
having a support system of women in tech
around you is critical so critical and
always remind ourselves but we make
those rooms better by being present in
them yes you better give us the whole
damn dollar and not a penny less
they're sending rockets into space they
themselves have said out loud
diversity is hard and it's so amazing
that you do robot Wow yeah maybe I can
be a role model for other girls who want
to go into tech because it can be scary
to not have somebody to look up to or to
see somebody else doing it let's do
better this is what a leader looks like
I belong here and I'm carving out my
space
awesome well thank you so much for
watching I hope you liked that video and
thank you so much again to built by
girls for letting me be a part of this
campaign being able to go to New York
City and meet the amazing team behind
built by girls they are just some of the
most warm and kind and passionate women
who are working towards something really
amazing and also being in the room again
for these awesome conversations that
happened that I hope happened more in
the tech industry thank you thank you so
so much for an incredible couple of days
and as always don't forget to like this
video is especially if you'd like to
learn more about organizations and
communities like this one that raise up
groups of people to be a part of the
tech industry and don't forget to smash
the subscribe button and the
notification valve to get notified for
my new videos all right well thank you
all so much for being here and thank you
for sticking around to the end and I
will see you next time bye oh my god
love built by girls and I'm not just
saying that cuz I'm in a campaign with
them I mean it's incredible the work
that they do and then what they've done
for girls